now is the time for you to turn your
great idea into a reality and
Squarespace is here to help you out they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project if you want to showcase
work or if you want to sell products of
any kind
they've beautiful templates and the
ability to customize just about anything
so you can make a beautiful website all
by yourself but if you do get stuck they
have 24/7 award-winning customer support
that is there to help so go to
Squarespace calm slash grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% of
your first purchase of a website or
domain hello and welcome to another
episode of not too deep I'm your host
grace Helbig if you're watching this
sorry for the strange background that's
happening but that's what's happening
everything is strange now except for
this episode with Akilah Hughes who I
absolutely love if you don't know her
get ready to fall in love with someone
that you've never met but you feel like
you do she is a youtuber a comedian
she's a political activist you might
know her from her podcast what a day you
might know her from her YouTube channel
Akilah obviously she's got a book we
talked about Animal Crossing how she's
been covering covent for months before
we all kind of knew about it and what
her experience that that has been we
talked about her journey from comedy in
New York with YouTube and it just it was
such a lovely conversation and something
I relate to very much I think she's
doing so much good in the world and
you'll get to hear about it firsthand on
this episode of not too deep with a kill
Hughes
[Music]
Akilah thank you so much for doing this
I am so excited to talk to you so one of
the questions I like to ask guests that
I think are so multifaceted and helps
people kind of get into who they are is
um what's your deal
what's my what's my problem I feel like
it you do so many different things you
wear so many different hats that how do
you like let's say an alien came down
and you're introducing yourself to the
first time and they wanted to know like
what your position is in the world how
do you describe that yeah oh man usually
I'm just like look I do a lot of stuff
like the most uncomfortable question for
a content creator too because it's like
I don't know how to like siphon this
down into the most like succinct thing
yeah but I mean I guess I would say that
the overarching theme of everything that
I do it's like all comedy you know I am
a comedian first and that's like
everything I've ever done in my career
was to the end of being like I'm funny
and I would like to make fun to things
yeah and so I think you know my book is
that when I go on podcast my podcast is
more new thank you for Kevin er of
course of course okay so everything you
do is comedy you create content your
host podcasts your in the political
world you're in the the activism world
you you came from Kentucky right yeah
like Kentucky like that's true
and so from Kentucky moved to New York
yes which was definitely some culture
shock gotta say I'm show us exactly what
everyone thinks the south also I'm using
a Boone oh my god feared that I realized
I was just moving a spoon across your
screen so this videos gonna be excellent
everyone has their versions of fidget
spinning and sometimes even to move
spoons so when you're growing up in
Kentucky how do you get into comedy how
do you where does that seed get planted
for you yeah I mean I gotta say like
there is no industry there right so it
really is just like a cultural thing and
I think that Kentucky is an interesting
place for comedy in so far as you know
everyone there thinks it's the best
place on earth but they've also never
been anywhere else okay insulated yeah
and so when you you know watch TV and I
watched a lot of TV and like movies and
all this stuff when you're a little kid
you're like but everywhere else looks
pretty awesome
like at least two black people
everywhere else one year they're like no
that's enough that's fine and so yeah I
think that I just became like just super
aware of the fact that everything in my
life was absurd like just living in like
a backwards reality and that is a place
that is rife for comedy sure yes so just
watching lots of like SNL and MADtv way
too young for sure like powers like
sixth grade and my teachers was like
your mom should be ashamed I'm like well
you're a bad teachers let's checks and
balances here
that's no same for me because I remember
my older brothers were really into they
watched S&L and they they would watch
Monty Python they were obsessed with and
I when I was in like fourth grade I was
watching it and not understanding at all
what it was but they would laugh and I
would just laugh when they would laugh
and assume like okay that was a funny
thing yes honey puss
yeah so then okay so it gets ingrained
in you a little bit you realize the
world is way bigger than Kentucky and
then you move to New York and is this
where you start like actually you moved
to pursue comedy yeah I mean I think
that there's probably a little bit of
space in between there where like
YouTube is invented right having College
and so that was like in Kentucky and
then so I've made all of these videos
none of them you know
it's very classic 2006 version of
youtubers like no one post consistently
no one's making money what is this thing
right it's a place to put like the
crappy like 1 pixel video from your
phone yes
yeah and so I was doing that forever but
I like really wanted to like do it
full-time
around 2012 and so 2011 I went to
playlist live I actually you will not
remember this but I met you there
probably yes it was very any Retd in a
bathroom and I was yeah and so but I was
just like I know that this is something
worth pursuing or at least like in my
mind it youtuber wasn't even really like
a common thing to even say back then so
I was thinking like I'm gonna use this
as a portfolio to like do comedy like I
don't have I don't know have any
connections so what I'll have is like
cool videos that I can write show
someone and then maybe I'll get an agent
yeah so there's no blueprint right
there's nothing there's nothing that
tells you how did I mean literally like
this is the newest career path none of
us had this growing up and sadly it is
wild that like at any point we're
supposed to know what we're doing I I
definitely didn't um but I knew I wanted
to move to New York and so I moved to
New York I read Mindy Kaling's book and
I was like I could be a babysitter and
then writes like an amazing play and
then yeah you're like here's the closest
thing I have to a blueprint so I'll
follow this thing I had same with me
Tina Facebook all of that I was like
here's this person did it this way so
what if I try it that way right and so I
moved to New York with two suitcases and
a dream I loved it old media and I make
terrible videos for another full year
and a half just like in my apartment and
then yeah I mean I think the real
catalyst for outward comedy like I was
doing sort of storytelling events I was
writing for hello giggles so they had
like live events and things and so that
was a way to build my community like in
New York and then you know I did you see
because UCB is what you do open your
face 2012 in New York
and which was great and like I think it
definitely stretched me in ways that
like I just was so closed off Kentucky
yeah and in 2013 I finally have a video
go viral and then the career is born Wow
and okay you must have felt this because
I definitely felt it because I did
improv at the pit and there was always a
very hesitancy and anxiety kind of
around being someone that did YouTube
stuff oh yeah in parallel to trying to
do like improving like you know hustle
rinde
that sort of right did you ever feel
like judged by like the people in the
actual comedy world cuz I always felt so
scared and like my my dork nerd YouTube
world I didn't want it to like bleed
into that world so much because people
just didn't understand it right they
definitely didn't understand like I
think they would have respected it more
if they knew how much work went into it
but there was Ray you know this was a
different time where people thought like
as long as it takes to watch videos how
long it takes to make one you do this
for 1 minute add a funny and I'm like do
you understand
learn several skills to do this yeah if
they could see how we just spent time
setting up what we're doing right now it
takes yeah and so I I still I think
sometimes you know at this point I think
more people online who like still [ __ ]
with me ya know me from other things but
like I still feel like there is some
stigma to it that is it's slowly fading
but it's like so it's like it's absurd
right it's yeah it's like if somebody
said well I don't like television and
I'm like well what about it like what is
it like one show like well it's all the
same as like is it yeah exactly that
it's taking the time to understand
something right and now they're all like
all the people who judge me are like
trying to get into this world and they
have their favorites and they love hot
ones and you know like they gay right
all this stuff and you know in ways I
feel vindicated but back then I definite
felt so left out kind of embarrassed
because it was like yeah oh I don't like
have like a rich family with connections
so I'm just here cuz I I do YouTube like
that's how I make enough money to pay
for this like and I really did I mean at
one point I know that um UCB was doing
YouTube videos and they only had a few
up at the time and I remember I was like
emailing every week I'm like I would
I'll be happy to come in on a weekend
and like help you with the camera stuff
whatever let's just want to be a part of
this I never had emailed back and then
my career starts popping off suddenly
it's like yeah oh um hi yeah let's put
her pictures up everywhere in the lobby
yeah like you want to ask a time like
you guys didn't even watch my tape when
I know you did it because I put it on
YouTube and it had the same number of
you guys don't let me quit play him
I know maybe go back through the inbox
and find that email from me from a
couple years ago begging for your
attention right now just like one bit of
affection you know but you hassled and
you did it and it's yeah I think it's
very very cool I also I was like looking
through everything of yours this morning
and your last video and your YouTube
channels from you know like 10 months
ago yeah you do you touch a little bit
on how YouTube has changed and everyone
has aged up do you it seems like you
know you your career has pivoted
obviously and you're much more involved
in politics do you feel the same like
when you go to sit down or think about
making a video for your channel do you
feel that sense because I definitely do
lately this like I don't want to I don't
know if this feels like right to do or
good to do I like doing my podcasts and
all this but YouTube feels a little bit
like a strange land to me right now yeah
no I think that like especially I mean I
consider myself like a YouTube native
like I started my channel in 2006 like
January so it's like you know like I
remember the beginning rained I think
that there was a time that
so magical that like I wish I could
bottle it up on the internet like
obviously there was the bad was still
there it just wasn't as amplified but at
the time specifically for creativity
where it's like there were so few videos
that it's like I would see one of your
videos and be like now it is my job to
make something as funny as that and like
whatever that means like not copy her
not try to be her not like you know like
glom on or try to start drama like just
yeah funny now like there was so much
permission in that and it was so new
that there was really no rule no
algorithm it was just like be better
than the last thing you saw yeah and I
think that now and for a while but I
haven't made like you said I have made a
video in 10 months I feel a really big
sense of relief about that but the
beginning was hesitancy and it was
because I was like this is what I do
like if I don't do this then like that I
don't have the other thing you know what
I mean like it just felt yeah it was
such a part of I mean it's why I got the
book deal you know like it's why I was
able to do like to pivot to anything
else and so there were feelings about
that well also I think it's just such a
fraught place I was you know I'm still
involved in a lawsuit with like someone
who ripped one of my videos just to post
it to you know sort of right-wing trolls
but just like what I did and posted it
and so like I've been harassed for years
about that and it's like after a certain
point I think you know I think that
initially when things started to feel a
little like okay am i - not even too old
because I don't think that that's a
thing like she's like that is 40 and
he's absolutely the right age for
YouTube to see what you know yes but I
think that I was like is my taste or my
ambition or even just like what I am
good at something that is well received
here anymore
and I don't I don't necessarily think
that it isn't it's just the amount of
work it took to make those things for
the return on investment was like why
like why not hitch this to someone who
will pay to do this like
yeah they're good ideas and I also don't
think that I'm like you know I think
YouTube was a place I wanted to start
but I had to remind myself like you came
here because you liked it as a portfolio
and like I never you know had ambitions
of being the most subscribed to person
or I mean like I wanted my videos to do
well obviously sure to see the work I
made but I think that I always thought
you know the freest version of this is
like a Donald Glover where you put a
bunch of weird videos on the internet
and then someone chooses you to like do
the thing and then you just get to go do
that and you know there were probably
three years and there were I was so
committed to not that to just being like
I love being on YouTube and I like
making videos every week and you know
god bless you for doing it every day I
remember I tried to do like so many Vita
sort of like over the course of 17 years
I've done like girl it's every one month
of April the reality is I was under
contract to so a lot of the the
mythology is that people think that that
was like a personal choice and so it was
a lovely thing and it really created
like an efficiency in my work ethic but
it was also a legal obligation like the
magic out of it sometimes yeah and I
mean I feel that way like like I love
doing my podcast so it's called what a
day it's on crooked NAT EFA those the
thing and congrats on you guys just hit
a hundred episodes right yeah oh my god
yes thank you so much I mean you get it
it is it's it's own grind on top of it
and order like the world we're living in
right now
exactly that's but I think that's so
cool because it seems like over the last
few years you really shifted your focus
into something that you're really
passionate about and it shows and that's
that's really what the start of YouTube
felt like for Chloe
it's like that same energy behind the
things that you're creating is still
there I'm curious like where I'm sure it
wasn't just a sudden overnight shift
that you're like I'm gonna talk about
politics now no more bedroom tours
that's like yeah how did that evolve for
you over time
because that's a very like that's a
world that I'm fascinated by I watch as
a bystander to be to do what you're
doing
is so admirable to me and also totally
terrifying because you're voluntarily
putting yourself in this gauntlet of
people to basically criticize you pick
apart everything you say yeah
even more than you know the average
thing that gets posted on YouTube so how
how did that kind of journey for lack of
a better word happen for you yeah that's
a great question um I think that it was
definitely gradual like it's definitely
like the frog in the boiling water yeah
yeah one day I was like oh it's hot like
yeah I think that everything changed
when Obama got elected and I think that
it was a perfect storm of the internet
finding its footing Obama getting
elected and then like sort of everything
that I think was a hunch to me being
like the little bit of diversity from a
small place I think it was it was man
this is like am I trying to formulate
the sentence we're getting there the
colony's hitting it no no no but but so
like Obama getting elected obviously you
yeah yeah change the world your eyes are
open to it you're engaging with it
you're participating in politics yeah
okay yeah yeah go ahead well I think
like just yeah so essentially it's like
you know you see that happen and at the
same time the Internet is getting bigger
like I mean Tumblr Pinterest Twitter is
finally finding its footing all this
stuff fast forward to like you know
around 2013 ish and all of these hunches
that I had is somebody growing up from
somewhere small about like the world
isn't really like this like there is
diversity we just don't see it reflected
and women are equal we just aren't given
the opportunities all of that stuff
stops being so taboo to talk about and I
think that that just became a natural
part of the conversation because shows
like girls were happening and shows like
scandal
where
like you know a black lead and it's not
about being a black person it's just a
show and so I think that all at once
everything sort of changed and I was
like oh all of the stuff that I've been
saying forever but I've been like really
quiet about cuz I'm you know I just want
to be accepted I don't want to ostracize
anyone whatever else like I don't want
to tell the truth for the sake of
telling the truth I just want to like
fit in you know I was like no like I
think we should tell the truth now and
when I started to do that I mean the
first video that I had that like went
viral was meet your first black
girlfriend which is a video about
interracial relationships vaguely about
a meet what I dated a youtuber and and I
remember being like so afraid to post it
like that i sat on it for like a week
and this is a video that like did well
the moment it hit the internet like
within a day hit a million views but I
was just like wow this is gonna be bad
like people are gonna hate that I'm
making jokes about white people I'm so
scared of them didn't like oh every
black person on earth was like standing
behind me now like yes yeah and so I
think that I just realized I'm like oh
tell the truth out loud who gives a [ __ ]
because like there's an audience and it
doesn't have to be like YouTube isn't
just one audience and I stopped I
stopped chasing you know what was sort
of a dominant audience and just being
like let me talk to the people who want
to hear this and I think that the pivot
more strongly is just like you know we
watch YouTube do like YouTube asks Obama
or the president or ever it is like
YouTube at the White House and it's it's
so exciting and then we get Donald Trump
as president which is its own thing and
like I'm not gonna belabor that point
but it's its own thing and suddenly
everything that was already like
starting to ramp up is like now we're at
a fever pitch because everything that I
think people were finally feeling
comfortable about like you know I don't
think that there was LGBTQ
representation like there has ever been
on like YouTube really kicked the door
in you know and was like we are here
we're not going anywhere and black
people on the line have like I mean vine
was just like an ally you provide just
like the entire internet like just
absolutely became this colorful
beautiful place that was as much as
there was bad there was
and suddenly it was like oh the bad is
creeping in and I'm like oh no I don't
think that I can make a video about
something that doesn't matter ever again
even though I did because you know
contracts also a businesswoman so yeah
yeah you can wait don't wait so we're
gonna we're gonna sell whatever this is
and then we're back to business on my
Twitter yeah I think that that was
really the catalyst and then you know
crooked media just found me one day and
I still don't know how they just
literally I got a cold email from this
woman Tonya who's like the head of
everything there she's live in New York
let's get coffee it was like okay so
yeah that's a that's like the windy road
to whatever I'm doing that's so cool
though and also like kudos to you that
you weren't catfished by someone saying
that they worked at crooked media oh I
just get murdered in the street I should
not have maybe trusted this but it seems
like you've really found your voice you
found your footing and you found the
like a driving creativity that it just
like resonates off of everything you
posts and everything you're doing right
now which is so cool to see especially
from someone that has started out on
YouTube so long ago and has watched all
of these trends and all of these ups and
downs happen
do you remember I'm curious the first
time you voted like ever ever or do you
remember like what that the feeling was
cuz I've even now I'm like 34 years old
and voting still I mean I do it every
chance I can get but it's such an
intimidating situation still I still
have this like anxiety about it a little
bit but do you remember that for you oh
yeah I mean mine was a very bizarre
situations the first election I ever
voted in was 2008 Barack Obama and those
I had just turned 18 that year all right
yeah 19 I don't know I'm old you're 19
whatever
I don't remember years anymore
it's an illusion right now right time is
everyday is day but I voted absentee so
I had a very bizarre voting experience I
was doing my college internship and at
this point I think I had like three
YouTube videos yeah and so I did my
internship at Disney World
working in Tomorrowland sellin hats you
know doing merchant Ament and yeah
everything's completely normal yeah like
super weird like my boss is almost
normal whatever got to be you've just
been living in a constant fever dream
your entire life
yeah like everyone's like aquila wake up
you're the Frog right it's so real and I
remember I lived in this amazing like
super international apartment complex so
the way they do their internships just
like briefly is that like they put all
of the college kids interns like twenty
thousand interns in three apartment
complexes okay I will chose the cheapest
one where you have the most roommates
and it's like a bajillion people it's
like horrible it literally you would
never stay there for any reason and I
remember I was dating this guy we
planned a party for that night one of my
roommates wasn't even there like her
family was visiting and they called it
so early and we all just like
instinctively ran out into like the
courtyard and it was like people from
everywhere in different languages
screaming yes we can' and banging things
like that voting experience was
literally like filling out a piece of
paper big like hope it gets there also
like right in Kentucky this is a purely
symbolic vote we're gonna really vote
for him yeah but that's so wait cuz mine
yeah mine was always absentee ballot it
to New Jersey then my mom would send me
and be like here now it's time and then
you send it off you're like I hope that
gets there like something could have
happened yeah I'm like this feels like a
Publishers Clearing House that I just
sent again but it's like it's for the
person that's gonna rule our country
right now
that letters journey is the journey of
babies day out could have fallen off a
truck gotta know the bottom of someone's
shoe we don't know I don't know who
knows if I ever actually [ __ ] it right
I know that's how I feel I'm like I
voted in every election I could have I
think yeah he's male yeah I gave it to a
man that looked like he handled mail so
hey okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back I have more questions
for you we also have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you it's gonna be really
fun we'll be right back with more not
too deep today we have support from
Squarespace it's about time for you to
turn your dream into a reality
Squarespace makes it easier than ever
for you to launch your passion project
are you looking to start a new business
showcased your work published content
sell products or more Squarespace is the
tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers you can customize just about
anything with a few clicks and you can
easily make a beautiful website by
yourself
Squarespace also has powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online a lot of us are trying
to do that and they have analytics that
help you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
your upgrade ever buying domains is
super simple and you can get the help
you need with Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms
to help them turn great ideas into
something real head to squarespace.com
slash grace for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch use the offer
code grace to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain again
that's squarespace.com slash grace offer
code grace okay
Akilah and everything that you've been
doing to help the world in these trying
times how is your animal crossing going
oh my gosh it's the best it's ever gonna
be
I'm not I don't know anything about it
Oh how do you what what is it okay so I
will tell you I have never played an
animal crossing game before this I don't
know if there were several before okay
okay
I do understand Mario Kart way better
now because there is no like a land that
you end up in that I'm like oh that's I
get it okay Animal Crossing is basically
you land on an island you are a person
but everyone you know is animals and
okay you have like two people that live
on your island and basically you just
grab stuff off the land sell it for
their currency which is called bells and
then you can build a house and you can
get like stuff and then you go to other
people's Islands and the whole like I
think the biggest thing is that the
island you go to has one kind of fruit
okay but you want all the kinds of fruit
and there's like six kinds I think
because the fruit sells for lots of
money if it's not your native fruit and
so you want to go to lots of other
islands and take the fruit and plant
trees on your own Island so you never
have to leave again
Wow so this is a little bit mapping over
our current situation yes how do I go
maybe I should get some like herb boxes
or something going at home literally
like the first day I think they did this
on purpose because it came out with 20th
and by this point a lot of states are on
lockdown and yeah they like a mask came
in like the mail system they're like I
have a face mask that I wear around the
island and I'm like should I wear it or
should the game yes
I'm practicing social distancing I'm not
I'm just stealing fruit and leaving
that's amazing I don't know what sort of
morals that's gonna translate to in real
life but it sounds fun how's that saying
they're cute
how have you is have been a primary
activity within your quarantine yeah and
like the good thing is it's a game that
you I mean literally it tells you how to
do everything from the beginning so I'm
like oh I have no gaming skills but
eventually this becomes like I know
where these buttons are and what they do
[Music]
yeah I like it is like it's so funny
I've never been a person who can
meditate but it's the closest I get to
being present because I cannot look at
my phone or anything else I'm like we
have to shake this tree we have to so
very stupid and I'm like I mean I am
embarrassed about my Island right now
I've been going at friends who like
don't have a job right now or like
they're just at home or or like they're
doing less and so they've been playing
for 150 hours they have like a music
studio they hotel and I'm like I have
literally a tent and a pile of fruit and
I don't think it's fair that we would
you would even visit me I am in squalor
and so this game that is supposed to be
giving you like an outlet to relax it's
now causing this new level of like
judgment and disruption like I'm mad I
go to people's places I'm like you guys
have like bricks on the ground like
where they're offering that enough money
for this I love it
well one thing that people can do in
quarantine if they don't have this game
as they can read your book which is very
exciting this came out at the end of
last year or last yeah last fall it came
out September 24th yeah I mean it's yeah
and it's short stories based on your
life and it's like a coming-of-age
memoir and it's written with comedy
obviously what what was the easiest and
hardest part to write in the book
because I'm always fascinated especially
with someone like you that like has been
online has been living your life out
loud on the internet and then to like
put it then into this tangible substance
that people can take with them yeah it's
such a different experience than just
turning on a camera and hitting record
yeah and it's definitely isolating in
different ways like I feel like as
YouTube I was like well eventually
someone will see it and then like their
comments will sustain me right and if it
doesn't work you move on to the next
video and this is like you can't it's
all there yeah and I'm like every year
I'm like it's gonna become less relevant
like we're already a pandemic what else
is gonna we're gonna be
for food and liked it yeah it was
definitely okay it's the easiest chapter
to write a chapter called the south it
is literally two sentences it's just
it's you know saying what is good about
the south and what is bad about the
south the difficult the most difficult
chapter I think it was probably the one
about friendship in like a comedy sphere
and like it's sort of about like female
friendships but really just like you
know when you don't even know that
you're competing with someone but they
feel that that's the case and like
getting sort of like kicked out of a
friend group because there's like just
there is a complete narrative that you
were unaware of right you thought you
were all just hanging out do the same
thing but other people saw it is like oh
no like this is a zero-sum game and like
if I if you're a comedian that I'm not
one so you have to die
right right it's like you're Fanning the
flames on this like trash fire that you
didn't even know was burning in your
group right
yes I'm like man how many karaoke nights
am I gonna go to her I think we're all
having fun and then I'm like there are
so many layers to this very fun outing I
thought we were having did you get any
feedback from people that were with all
them summer yes oh yeah oh man the shade
is it's like it's a beautiful thing
because it's like I was so scared I
never heard from the people it was about
because obviously they don't read but
the people who knew were like ooh hmm
and I guess one bit of good news is that
like this isn't just talking [ __ ] I
literally have confronted this person of
mine okay
we're like sounds so corny I'm like
weird though it's like what is
confronting somewhat a light-up like
here's me typing a sentence like she
chided another sentence I'm typing wood
back you know I think it's like a pretty
public like whoo I don't [ __ ] with ya
yeah so it was just worthwhile to like
be able to at least put that outside of
the confines of like 140 characters and
being like
there's actually the history because you
get some context right right this isn't
coming out of nowhere yeah and it must
be really cathartic to actually put that
on paper and to have like elegantly and
completely have the whole narrative out
there yes sort of like put it out okay
so talking about like confronting people
online and that sort of thing how do you
because like I keep saying you're so
involved in the things that are
happening in the world obviously you're
posting things with your opinion and
people fight back no matter what your
opinion literally anything
yeah do you have like a set of standards
for yourself and like how you post or
what you post or like do you have to
catch yourself from getting caught up in
people commenting certain things oh yeah
I mean and it's something that I I think
everyone could get better at myself
because I'm like damn am I really
replying to this person who like
literally doesn't follow me would never
know if I saw this but there's just
there's that thing that will give you
and you'll fall asleep thinking about it
you're like I don't need to let them
know I see what they're saying to me and
like I think that there is something
very human about like not liking being
misunderstood yes it's like I find
myself most of the facts I have online
are like one tweet and I'm like that's
not what I said
like just let them not know how to read
like why am i right people love reading
police like literally just a few days
ago on the animal crossing tip I this
was I was like I did I just found out
how to run across the street and it was
by accident
I've been whacking doing all this no
wonder everybody's further in I was like
did you know that you could do this this
is this could did you know you could eat
the eggs I'm like I know everything else
it was just so yeah it's pretty
ridiculous but I did say that you
tweeted I think was yesterday that you
were tweeting like
with everything our president it's
whatever but you were like don't tweet
like him like that's what will continue
to divide us and I just thought that was
such a beautiful way of handling this
situation because it's so easy to stoop
to someone's level and reminding
yourself that like yeah what's that
going to accomplish that's only gonna
create worse things for all of us and I
was like I love this this is so
refreshing and lovely I just like a nice
reminder of like you're better than that
yes well thank you I mean I I'm not I'm
trash but because I'm sure with it and
having tweeted that within two hours I
was like you're an idiot disappointed
you gotta balance yourself out that's a
big C relatable authentic transparent oh
yeah exactly and when you know when time
is just a concept like the time Megan
now I'm like perhaps I tweeted that
before I said the other thing we don't
know for sure is a new era exactly my
god is so true okay with what a day
let's talk a little bit about this
because you guys like I said just in
your 100th episode and what is the
what's the the goal when you guys are
doing this podcast is it to speak to a
younger audience to try and keep them
informed like what is what do you guide
you create this world yeah I mean that
is so that's a very that's give me an
involved answer yeah sure because you
know it's like any job where there
wasn't a blueprint at all like right
there
obviously have been daily news shows and
so it's like are we gonna be Michael
Barbara with the New York Times
obviously not what she does not have
this hair for one like I think that what
we knew people wanted was like everyone
is tired of the news there's too much
news yes which is funny because now all
anybody watches it's because at the end
of times yes um but it at the time so
this fall this past fall right after my
book came out it was like great let's
hit the ground running creating what
could be a 15 minute show that tells you
what you need to know first thing in the
morning and then you don't have to
follow the news all day
minute to minute on Twitter you can just
have a life and then tomorrow morning
you'll know what happened like it's
pressing we will post about it but like
truly this is that that was the real
overarching theme it was also your doing
the good work for everyone you're
simplifying it for everyone that yeah
that must be a lot to take on oh yeah I
mean it's also just not a skill I had
before this like I've never had
ambitions of being a teacher necessarily
although I think that like being
comedian is being observant and then
like relaying what you've learned
yeah it wasn't like I have to understand
this and then regurgitate it to people
and so that was a huge learning curve
for me my co-host Gideon is like an
amazing reporter but like he didn't
really have podcasting experience or
like performance experiences on this
thing and so I think that we got really
lucky being paired together after like
several and you know auditions with
different people for chemistry but like
what we knew initially was that like
we're both kind of goofy it should be
funny because cricket tends to do like
comedy but also politics like that's the
marriage and I think that our audience
just you know I don't know that they're
necessarily a specific age but they are
like it's not the news junkies who want
to listen to like NPR and New York you
know the New York Times podcast in the
morning they want to just be like I want
to sound smart when I talk to my friends
I want to know what's happening and I
want to like I think the other thing
that we do that other shows don't is
like give people ways to actually be
active like here's a charity you can
throw money at here's who you can like
here's how you get involved go to this
website they'll tell you how you can go
door-to-door doing whatever I mean not
anymore but you know three weeks ago I
could leave your house there was a time
yeah and so I think that like that was
really the goal and a hundred episodes
over the course of like six ish months
is you know really no slouch in like we
just had to yeah we had terrible
episodes in the beginning we had good
episodes in the beginning and now I
think when we found our footing maybe in
the beginning of the year everything
changed so quickly and we reported on
coronavirus the moment it was news like
yeah you've been covering
for January right and so like I think
that the the show ended up finding Edie
you know it found its one groove and
then immediately found like just pivoted
and somehow really I think stuck the
landing but I think it was the benefit
of having been covering it for so long
like I really do think we beat the other
big daily news shows to talking about it
but we also were like what is this six
people dying that's not that bad
right and every day it's like the slow
motion of like oh oh no it's a different
country no [ __ ] there's another cruise
ship and then like in forever so I think
that like the moment that we're all like
the culturally in America we're in
because this is just now happening here
whereas like you know everywhere else
has a two-month Head Start I think my
emotional states and like my ability to
do the job has only been improved by the
fact that like I've seen this coming in
slow motion for like like I watched what
happened everywhere else and so it's
like I I guess I don't get as caught up
in the daily bits of it because I'm like
no this is this has been life for me ya
know ya even know separate lying yeah
yeah we're all catching up to where
you're at right now basically there so
like you know you're gonna get on my
island this is how you relax you like
even edible at night and you just shut
it and you're just running around in the
dark that's you are speaking my language
well so did what else have you been
doing on a relaxing side like what do
you watch when you watch things so if
you watch funny I I try to watch
relaxing things but like my housemate is
like this very cool 28 year old guy but
so like I feel like we often end up
watching intense things if we're both in
the living room but I have like my own
space with the TV so I watch my own ship
but together we watched Ozark I just I
couldn't watch the finale yet I was like
I can't finish I just got into Ozark boy
just got me into it
we just finished season two
we just started season three and yeah
it's intense I've been using it as like
escape from the world let's watch Ozark
and then realize in like oh this is a
different type of tension that happens
okay it's exactly right of like oh
that's how you knock yourself out of a
current trauma one yes and yeah so I
mean I love it and I will tell you no
spoilers
you are going to love this season and
there is a guest star new character that
I was like no one's gonna be as good as
Julia Garner on the show she's a genius
and I'm like he is so good oh so - I
can't wait you're gonna love it
um but so I've watched that and then I
have this real habit of like there's too
much choice like I went to kwibi and I
was like all of this looks good but it's
also like I don't know if I'm ready for
seven minutes of Christoph Waltz you
know for two hours or nothing so yeah
that looks good I just don't think I'm
ready for what you having so I have a
list of things to watch but I end up
rewatching the same thing so my real go
twos are fantastic mr. Fox nice just
like wow these colors are calming and
like as the time I'm stoned I'm adding
that to my nighttime viewing I have you
totally forgotten about that thank you I
think you will literally melt into your
couch and be like this is like a hug
from childhood I'm so cuz I've been
waiting great british baking show is
like that for me and that hasn't come
back yet so I need something to fill the
void yeah so it's a lot of that and then
I'm I love Gentlemen Prefer Blondes I
don't know if you know that this is um I
would say Marilyn Monroe at her best is
the one where she does diamonds are a
girl's best friend in the beautiful
dress with all the people but it is like
grace I'm telling you like the color
palette the songs like the acting the
jokes are so much further out than you
would think is possible for the 50s
or I'm so excited it's like you have to
watch it I think it's on Amazon if it's
not I'm a liar well
great all I can say is because I bought
it so I'm going it somewhere yeah um but
you will be like oh this is uproariously
funny in a way that nothing is like it
was the first time I saw it I was like
whatever I don't know [ __ ] about
anything yeah yeah it in the old movies
because I used to hate old movies yeah
and I I like there's something about it
to me that is almost hypnotic because
I'm like this is like seeing the first
YouTube video where you're like you can
do that but like six years oh my gosh I
can't wait I gotta say I think you will
you just have to message me when you
watch it and like sex I'll be like cool
no I have bad days so I don't know I
think it's gonna be great I can't wait
okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back with a lot of really
fun Twitter questions for you so I'll be
right back with more not too deep sports
research is your one-stop-shop for a
lifetime of performance health and
wellness through the makers of the
highest rated collagen peptide product
on Amazon and their flagship product
sweet sweat sweating helps burn calories
and sweet sweat activated by your
elevated heart rate helps increase
sweating during exercise look at this
science you can simply apply the gel
which comes in a variety of pleasing
sense too slow to respond problem areas
before your workout for best results use
sweet sweat in combination with sports
researches best-selling waist trimmers
like their new neon waist trimmer
collection and did you know that
collagen is vital to help support the
health of your skin hair nails and
connective tissues well that's why you
should try sports researches third party
certified and non-gmo verified collagen
peptides which provide the best product
at the best price offered in a variety
of flavors sports research collagen
peptides can be added to coffee soup
sauces or more at home or on the go look
at all of these treasures for you and
you have a special offer coming your way
if you go to sports research calm and
use the code grace at checkout right now
you'll get 20% off your order that's 20%
off site-wide
at sports research calm
with code grace at checkout did you know
that there's a company that's mastered
the science of sparkle meat light box
lab grown diamonds they hacked a
billion-year process to grow stunning
lab-grown diamond stones in about two
weeks and they're some of the highest
quality stones that exist they're always
near colorless always vs clarity always
a very good cut and always $800 per
carat they come in three colors to white
blush pink and soft blue after they're
grown in the lab they're transformed
into gorgeous lab-grown diamond jewelry
it's Beauty meets brain go to light box
jewelry calm slash Grace and use code
grace for $25 off that's light box
jewelry dot-com slash grace
use code grace for $25 off okay Akilah
before we get into the Twitter questions
I'm gonna ask you the two questions
asked every single guest that's on the
podcast and then the first is who alive
or dead would you most like to throw
cold spaghetti at I mean
Milania that's really good I don't think
she would react I think she was just
keep talking right and then I feel like
you would get to really find out if it
was her or her stunt double yeah it just
starts like one I just starts like
glitching yeah I knew it
yes that's Madame Tussauds Wax figure
that's not her okay be best Milania be
best the other question has every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or a close call but you
can only use three words or three small
phrases so mine for example is college
jogging front lawn ooh yeah very
athletic [ __ ] or it could be like a
sort of bathroom emergency such okay
that works
all right I the most iconic one in my
mind um big gulp
oh no gas station yeah third word could
it be a phrase sure all over my shorts
pickles don't end well they're too big
it was too much Mountain Dew and I have
never had not do ever against it I love
it
ok let's get into these Twitter
questions um let's see we have one that
says Oh an important question what do
you miss about Neopets oh my gosh you
know what I miss I miss the omelet I
think that like there's not a free thing
online that's satisfying as being like I
can feed my pets for free to say I don't
know what it's gonna be but they like it
all they're never like I hate this
broccoli on what they're so great can
Twitter give me something for free every
day right besides like disappointment
yes ok Neopets for people that don't
know it's basically this keychain device
and you have Oh head don't you think not
bad
wait what am I thinking of I think I got
cheese yeah Tamagotchi and Giga pets and
Giga me assets are similar there but
it's all online so it's like site and
it's like you're role-playing with your
dumb like fake animal and you go to the
omelet it's like cooking I don't know
I'm acting like it's a thing that you
have to be right about and it makes me
fully understand your relationship with
Animal Crossing now yeah yeah a little
loves pets if you have a history with
Neopets I can understand the evolution
to Animal Crossing No
okay someone is asking you have you
gotten cherries yet do you need any
other type of fruit they have pears
oranges and peaches this comes from the
chow style if you need to get in touch
ooh thank you so much um I was posting a
lot about the cherries and I did I'm
happy to report I got cherries I planted
like several trees so I am I have all
the fruits now yeah
we're making fruit money on my island oh
yeah okay we can all rest easy deal and
bond is asking that she's mentioned
struggling with being
in so deep with the news in the past has
it gotten better or worse lately oh I
mean it's definitely worse I think that
you can't turn off the news now which
makes it so much harder to separate like
before you know in the fall it's like
I'm reporting on the primary I'm
reporting on you know there's bad news
and whatever else but it feels like
there's a distance yeah and it's like oh
I get done doing my job and then I call
my mom and she's like hey so I've been
like pandemic shopping and yeah I have
to like live it now right it's also must
be strange for you because just on like
as a person that is a member of society
it feels like an obligation to keep up
with the news just to be informed on a
regular basis especially with everything
that's changing and you know wanting to
abide by rules and practices but also
for you it's your job so there's a
double necessity for you to be observing
it and in it and absorbing it so it must
feel like think I'm really happy for you
that you have animal crossing to kind of
separate obviously like let's just bless
up to animal crossing you came at the
right time I don't know what I wanna
snow what I'd be doing I'd probably be
replaying like some other video game and
I'm not good at video games like this is
a thing I play a lot I love it the in
line with that someone else is asking
does she get a break from it and what do
you do to keep yourself sane who I mean
I think my sanity you know I have a
therapist I'm very privileged to have
someone to like dump stuff on one
schoiar week yeah I'm like hey get
online I got a dump my feelings and
she's like okay well I'm not going
through anything at all like I don't
want to hear but yeah that's really it I
think that like and I talked to my
friends more than ever which is good you
know I moved to LA just last fall and so
most of my friends are still in New York
which is getting the worst of it
and I think it's been it's been nice to
at least be able to check in with those
people and like feel closer to like home
because I feel like I'm sure I don't
know I'm watching New York burn down
from my car that got to me like this is
not good yeah I mean it's hard that's
two very difficult seeing them in New
York but I think the big thing that I've
been seeing an experience for myself too
is like check in on your friends and
like you know don't be afraid to like
reach out and like for any reason it's
just so necessary right now yeah and
everybody is going through it like even
the people who don't reach out it's not
because they're like [ __ ] it's just
like who has the energy to exactly be
proactive so it's like if you have even
an ounce of it and you're like
questioning just I mean what [ __ ] is
gonna be like don't talk to me did
something terrible to them then that's
maybe something to get sorted out in a
different way yeah someone to know your
favorite quarantined snack or drink
well the drink is just straight-up red
wine I became Hoda Kotb the day we got
stuck in the house it's good and yeah I
she's it's more a thing that I had a
rule against buying because I will like
it's not even about like I'm a healthy
person it's literally just that like if
I have a box of cheez-its that's what
I'm eating this weekend I'm not having a
vegetable it's just getting to
completion the cheez-its
i hundred-percent understand that on a
very deep emotional level yeah this is
one serving and it's gonna go for the
whole day that's not like my body does
it want a process that I'm eating yeah
my brain and my body are at odds right
now and sometimes you know I gotta I got
to serve my brain a little bit
luckily so yeah I'm deep in cheese at
land love it okay jessica is asking can
she please regale us with a story of a
karaoke party with Ronan Farrow who did
this happen yes this happened so okay
Ronan Farrow is engaged to John Lovett
who is a good friend of mine who works
at crooked media
I met Ronan we were doing the pod to
America HBO shows and so I was opening
for them each weekend like on the road
after he did the correspondent work for
that and so we were in Philadelphia and
Ronan was there and he was like
reporting like in the back room and he's
like there to surprise John but John is
not a person who likes surprises so I
was like hanging out with him so we
became friends and we so I've been to
two of his birthday parties they are
almost always pajama themed and the last
one I went to was in this past December
he had karaoke I guess the story the
quickest story I can tell is that there
was a pretty strong New York contingent
there that's not a word New York cohort
there and like my housemate who's also
like he produces for Jesus tomorrow so
like they were there and like my Gideon
was there I was there it was kind of
weird list plank was there we were all
there and long story long they're like
cool so we're gonna dance for a while
and then like whoever wants to do
karaoke we're like great let's like skip
the dancing go straight to one is like
at the level but we're like whatever
like yeah
yeah Ronan didn't make a speech no one's
saying happy birthday he just like went
up there and I was mostly filming this
but Jesus and ziwei who's a comedian
decided to do shallow you know that he's
very Bronx so it was a lot of just like
tell me saw just like turning around
slowly
something's happening and it was great
cuz Ronan was just like I love my
birthday like he doesn't he doesn't need
things to go well yeah party what a
great gift in and of itself also I love
it I love straight to karaoke we can cut
out this middle part the day yeah who
has to be drunk by talent if this will
be drunk on songs and they're like no
one agrees with that that's not the
thing people say
okay someone wants to know thoughts on
living in Los Angeles and not in New
York at the moment you've touched on
this a little bit yeah I mean sorry I
have a little I've like a little little
swallow happening oh yeah
grabs it emotional it's an emotional
response I'm like my body just woke up
you know I think I'm I'm obviously happy
to be safe and in Los Angeles and I like
having the space here like I have an
indoor and outdoor space and so it's
like not as confined as it would be in
New York I also like just live with the
one person and we're like chillin hey
Eric I lived in like a building with
several people who touch things that I'm
like I think I would just be a nervous
wreck yeah but I think that there is
just like something about the distance
that it's just it's sad and if anything
were to happen to someone I know there
and like I know I can't go to like a
funeral I can't go be with them and so I
think there's it's that's its own set of
anxiety of just being like so far away
yeah but I think that like you know in a
Darwin way I'm like I guess it is good
yeah I'm not there right now I'm trying
to find a silver lining
yeah ya know and that's all you can do
is try to figure out like what is the
bright side of this situation right now
okay last question someone to know what
a day are you having
what a cute cutie
okay um today is good you know what's
funny is since every day blends together
now yes I I always say I'm like I don't
know how I'm surprised by my emotion
first thing the morning every day like
it's gonna be like rage we're just like
completely dulled out like grass of like
I don't know who cares yeah or it's just
like inconsolable crying and then some
days it's just like this is a good day
and today I'm like this is this is fine
I haven't read the news yet that's I
know that's that'll really decide the
tone yeah oh yeah I mean jeez it's like
remember when there was a first time
like things just started getting really
bad in America with like all news I
guess with yeah just like day after day
and then you would get online and be
like I should check the news before I
make a joke because I might be like I
need to read the room say no I'm like
jokes or did yeah
it's yeah trying to be respectful of the
universal tone of the world and also
contribute content is a very difficult
thing to manage right now yeah okay
Akilah thank you so much for being here
and doing this podcast with us remotely
usually when we're in person we have a
fortune cookie that is our gift from us
to you that is a personalized fortune
cookie but we're gonna try and do it
virtually right now so Melissa just sent
you a little document in the chat if you
open that up it should be a beautiful
image of your personalized fortune
cookie if you here we go read it out
loud nice I apologize it's all good what
a day instead as what a decade of a
smashed into a day but what even is a
day anymore no really what day is it the
podcast well that's your fortune from us
to you I love that fortune I feel
fortunate would even write that in order
deal bad that you couldn't see me
reading it so if there's some way for
you all to get that animation yeah it'll
get out we have a huge budget will get
the animators on it CG I am just CGI in
footage of my mouth moving to make it's
exactly
Akilah where can people find everything
that you're up to if they don't already
know Lou okay so I live on the Internet
follow me on Twitter at Akilah obviously
if you spell it with an aki it should
come up and I have a new series coming
to Comedy Central's social media
channels whoa Fridays in April it's
called making fun with akela and Malana
it's me and Milan a vine troupe and
amazing lovely Hume yes and yeah listen
to what a day on cricket media podcast
and buy my book obviously series from
Thailand I have given you a million
things to do so if you check one of them
I will be grateful yes you guys cannot
complain that you have nothing to read
or watch or listen to because I got you
covered of media again video I give you
a few words you really did give me an
entire like summer activities list
thank you very much this has been so fun
you guys go check out akela if you
haven't already obviously she is
wonderful so we'll see you guys next
time on another episode of not too deep
goodbye too deep
toady toady not too deep is a production
of grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa Dee months edited by Shireen
Lonnie Eunice post production sound by
Chris Henry and an extra special thanks
to Flula for the theme music
[Music]